le camion presque neuf qui lui permet de
rouler et de gagner sa vie
le rêve d'enfance pour s'y tient j'adore
ces moments de passion j'ai rêvé de
faire ça toute ma vie mais une passion
qui vient avec son lot de l'ifi des
autres c'est pas un travail facile on a
beaucoup de stress les gens pensent
qu'on puisse conduire un camion mais
c'est beaucoup plus que ça pour sauver
la répartition du poids de notre
chargement la sécurité évidemment qui
est primordial on doit penser à la
sécurité tout le monde autour de nous
même si on ne connaît pas encore les
causes de l'accident de l'autoroute 440
cynthia est persuadé qu'on aurait pu
l'éviter et je trouve ça très triste
parce qu'il ya eu vraiment beaucoup des
défis communs à toutes les semaines
puis on s'entend que ces desserts 100%
évitable mais la réalité aujourd'hui
c'est simplement nos autoroutes sont
ultra occupé comme plus d'heures de
pointe maintenant c'est l'heure de
pointe et tout le temps les gens sont
super précis elle croit avant tout que
les conducteurs sont imprudents
téméraire et surtout impatient en
seulement 30 minutes passées à bord de
son carrosse mais de ce côté là mais moi
j'ai des surprises là j'en ai un qui me
sort on comprend ce qu'elle veut dire
ici c'est un coin où c'est moi qui a
priori tu es un gars les gens me
regardent
tec est si tu prend pour acquis que ta
priorité puisque juste continuer ben ça
risque d'être un peu plus loin
l'histoire sur précieux soit la gamme
wager priorité lui s'en vient de couper
sans bien voilà il est avec lequel mme à
passer sur le trottoir passe en avant -
et cinq minutes plus tard
donc voyez ici c'est une voie mais là
monsieur ici à ma gauche paris tente pas
d'attendre que je tourne le coin fait
qu'il veuille se met à côté de moi pour
pouvoir me déplacer avec la lumière ton
univers mais il ne jette pas le blâmer
uniquement sur les automobilistes
même les camionneurs selon elles
prennent des risques inutiles c'est
99.999 % des réponses chela
donnes tu expliques a fait des pointes
et de l'enfant
la scène mickey
y'a vraiment problématique puis moi je
le vois de plus en plus chez les
camionneurs décourage on veut vous faire
une démonstration aujourd'hui de
l'espace du parc en a besoin
s'ils attendent depuis longtemps de
sensibiliser la population en publiant
de nombreuses usines mais est on la voit
comme celle ci où elle démontre que si
une petite voiture se classent trop près
de son camion où la voiture de vie
complètement invisible parce qu'on voit
pas ce qu'est en avant envoyez le tour
et on hurle et cette autre vidéo à
seulement 43 km heure le camion englouti
la voiture s'ajoutent à l'imprudence des
routes inadaptées pour le nombre de
véhicules qui circulent des routes trop
petit
des voix trop courtes trop vieille qui
aurait besoin d'une sérieuse cure de
rajeunissement le gouvernement
reconnaître le réseau routier a besoin
d'être améliorée et promet des mesures
immédiates et à long terme la voie
simple la ligne peinture et simple qui
nous qui appellent les automobilistes de
rentrer directement par la voie de
service sera prolongée en amont mais
selon l'expérience de cynthia ça ne
changera pas grand chose
moi je voudrais qu'ils aillent lindo
blanc n'est pas la majorité mais
c'est par la sensibilisation et
l'éducation qu'on aidera la cohabitation
camions voitures croit-elle devançant
d'un jeu vidéo électro binôme et non on
en aura trop
ici et les à céret rade au canada
montréal